wir haben es angesprochen es gibt auch
hoffnung im kampf gegen omikron kann
wohl bald ein weiterer impfstoff zum
einsatz kommen er und zwar nur war
baxmeyer lauterbach rechnet noch mit
heute mit einer zulassung durch die
europäische arzneimittelagentur
der neue sogenannte proteine im stoff
von nowaks ist aufgebaut wie der als
bekannte und bewährte impfstoff genau
und die hoffnung dieses ähnlichen grippe
impfstoff das eben eben impfgegner
deshalb weniger skeptisch
gegenüberstehen als den neu entwickelten
impfstoff mit denen es ja weniger
erfahrungen gibt doch was genau ist an
nova weg so anders darüber wollen wir
jetzt mit dem hausarzt und internisten
dr thomas aßmann sprechender bild
hausarzt also zu sagen wir morgen
erstmal morgen für größere maschine um
die versorgung des impfens natürlich
direkt zum impfstoff zu nur was wie sich
schon richtig sagten das ist praktisch
old school mäßig es werden protein
stückchen also ein stückchen im körper
gezeigt im immunsystem und der bildet
dann antikörper bei dem
stoff dem er bis jetzt hatten es so dass
der impfstoff geimpft wird in den muskel
dann wandert er in die körperzellen und
produziert praktisch die körperzelle
selber diese protein stücke die dem
virus ähnlich sind und darauf reagiert
dann der körper beziehungsweise das
immunsystem so auch der impfstoff der
neue ist recht gut man muss aber dazu
sagen dass die wirksamkeit von 90
prozent die erreicht hat noch bei der
sogenannten alpha variante sind wir sind
ja jetzt schon bei delta und oregon
begrüßt um die ecke beziehungsweise ist
auch schon da wir wissen nicht wie
gerade die wirkung ist das zweite ist
dass zwar die antikörperproduktion
angeregt wird aber nicht diese monti
t-zellen das ist die zweite abwehrlinie
die unser körper hat das aber beim
aber zusammen zu fassen es ist ein
zweiter fall köcher und jede möglichkeit
gegen den airbus anzukommen ist eine
gute sache vielleicht auch das dann auch
die impfgegner die angst haben vor
diesem neuen mr neheim stoff sich darauf
einigen können diesen impfstoff zu
nehmen besser den ausgang also alles was
wir haben das hambacher aber man fragt
sich dennoch wenn die ema die zulassung
gibt dann heißt es ja noch lange nicht
dass es dann gleich in den nächsten
stunden oder tagen auch in deutschland
die stieg oder nachzieht was glauben sie
wie lange wird das dauern bis wir diesen
impfstoff dann auch wirklich hier in
deutschland haben und für wen ist er
überhaupt auch zulässig also da hatten
wir auch in den vergangenen zeiten immer
mal wieder nochmal korrekturen nach oben
nach unten über 60 unter 30 also für wen
er könnte überhaupt dieser impfstoff
wirksam und zulässig sein
also ich kann ihnen sagen
weihnachtssaison 25 12 der ist aber
verimpft werte im stoff das kann ihnen
natürlich nicht sagen aber ich denke das
ist relativ zeitnah erfolgen wird ich
denke in den nächsten drei bis fünf
wochen dass das dann schon losgeht und
natürlich erstmal für die gruppe ab 18
ja wie die studienlage jetzt für die
gruppe der kinder ist zwölf bis achtzehn
muss man noch abwarten aber da laufen
auch die studien aber der impfstoff soll
an sich sehr gut verträglich sein das
problem ist einfach wie ist der wirksam
gegen den neuen virus also mit anderen
worten wir haben eine chance da noch
mehr leute zu erreichen vielleicht auch
die skeptisch sind gerade auch angst um
ihre kinder haben aber wir müssen
richtig gas geben
erst mal noch eine frage zu einem thema
das uns heute morgen etwas erschreckt
hat in attendorn dass es den kreis olpe
in nordrhein westfalen wurde kindern
unter 12 jahren versehentlich moderner
als impfstoff gespritzt und nicht so wie
es zugelassen ist biontech moderner ist
nicht zugelassen für kinder unter 12
jahre wird sogar für menschen nach der
empfehlung der deutschen ständigen
impfkommission menschen unter 30 jahre
gar nicht empfohlen weil es eben
nebenwirkungen wie herzmuskelschwäche
gab wie gefährlich ist das jetzt für die
kinder die eltern machen sich natürlich
extreme sorgen haben den fall auch
angezeigt
ja ich kann das gut nachvollziehen dass
gerade auch dass die eltern in sorge
sind aber man muss jetzt von
normalerweise hat das keinerlei
auswirkungen weil man will bei
impfstoffen absolute oder höchstmögliche
sicherheit geben deswegen wurde es halt
nur bei menschen über 30 gegeben aber
auch da unter 30 ist es wirkungs oder
das nebenwirkungsprofil ganz gering nur
ein kleines beispiel die us armee hat
ihren deutschland letzte woche eine
große aktion gemacht der aufrüstung und
da war der da waren die meisten unter 30
die wahl zwischen 20 und 25 und mir da
us berichtet haben gab es
22 richtlinien einmal die moderne linie
und einmal bei und tech linie die
moderne linie war bei dsds voll und
keiner wollte bei und tec haben also man
muss so sagen ich glaube dass auch
vielleicht ein bisschen kulturell und
was man nicht kennt und so weiter
dagegen geschuldet also das was enorm
passiert ist sollte an sich nicht
passieren aber ich glaube nicht dass das
ein ganz großer grund sich große ängste
zu machen also entwarnung für die eltern
die jetzt natürlich in sorge sind von dr
thomas aßmann uns zugeschaltet aus dem
maschinenraum da bauen wir sie auch
nicht weiter stören und danken ganz
herzlich für das gespräch anspruch hat
herzlichen dank bleiben wieso negativ
und wenn ich das so sehe was jetzt auf
uns zurollt um sich ein bisschen vorräte